mon nom est ahmed awan
nous allons faire quelques vidéos en ce moment
je vais vous donner quarante dollars en cinq
secondes pour saisir ce que vous voulez vous
obtenez cette question bien d'
accord le défi medi est
essentiellement un défi où j'aide ma
communauté
ils  obtenir la bonne question, ils peuvent
saisir tout ce qu'ils veulent gratuitement,
vous savez, comme je suis viral, il y a beaucoup de gens que
j'ai rencontrés,
je vais vous donner ce panier de basket en
cinq secondes pour saisir ce que vous voulez,
posez cette question correctement
allez en prendre deux
et wow
je me réveille tous les jours
tôt le matin comme cinq heures du
matin
je prie
faire des prières un jour va bien et
ça répand toujours l'amour et dire euh
saluer ta famille et être reconnaissant
de vivre  voir un autre jour
[Musique] en
ce moment, il est actuellement six heures du
matin,
six heures du matin,
ils travaillent tous dur,
c'est un train local 5 à destination de Manhattan,
vous devez avoir ce type d'énergie avec
vous parce que n'importe qui peut vous enjamber dans
le bronx gi  ve you that thumbs
je suis un gars vraiment sympa tu sais mais quand
il s'agit de mauvaises personnes
je suis un méchant
je parle juste maintenant
[Musique]
ce magasin est comme ma deuxième maison
à l'âge de 10 11 j'ai commencé  travailler à
la caisse a commencé à s'occuper de quelques-
uns de mes clients a
commencé à connaître la communauté
ce sont de bonnes personnes
hé le ministre et son père de bonnes personnes
mec
tu sais que
tu la connais quatre ans nous sommes comme une
famille la
plupart du temps  c'est moi et mes frères
parce que vous savez que nous essayons d'aider mon
père, vous savez qu'il travaille depuis
très longtemps, il soutient la
famille depuis très longtemps,
il est temps d'intervenir et de les aider
[Musique]
qui  je veux toujours prendre le relais pour être
honnête non je n'ai jamais voulu que mon avenir soit
dans le magasin
parce que tu sais que j'étais j'étais dans les
magasins depuis que je suis un petit enfant
donc j'étais comme tu sais je veux faire
autre chose
je  veux être différent de ta famille
parce que tu sais que beaucoup de yéménites sont
connus pour avoir un corps  egas dans les magasins
et pas tant que ça, je veux dire faire des films et
tout,
donc je voulais être le seul et j'ai pensé
à une bonne idée
et c'est devenu viral, laissez-moi m'occuper de
lui
350. merci
oui quand mes vidéos sont devenues
virales j'étais vraiment  excité et je ne pouvais pas y
croire et vous savez que la meilleure chose
à ce sujet est que
barack obama m'a tweeté
et j'étais vraiment fou j'étais sur tous
les organes de presse après cela
et c'était fou vous savez
une installation très familière
vous d'abord ce qui est 10 fois 10 100  .
corrigez ce qui est 10
moins cinq correct dieu vous bénisse vous êtes
gentil
merci beaucoup cinq
quatre attrapez beaucoup de trucs les gars vous pouvez les
aider aussi cinq
quatre deux
trois
faire ces vidéos pour les voir courir en
attrapant ce qu'ils veulent
l'excitation  dans leur visage je ne
sais même pas que tu aimes l'avocat
j'aime les avocats tu manges tout en
bonne santé maman
ils sont si heureux parce qu'ils aiment le tiktok
donc c'était une vraie bénédiction pour eux
ces enfants mangent beaucoup ils ne mangent pas juste
trois repas tu sais  ils mangent  comme quatre
ou cinq repas par jour
donc c'est ouais c'est une bénédiction jus d'
uruz et nouilles dont ils ont besoin
qu'il soit bon pour la communauté je l'aime
[Musique]
je te donnerai cinquante dollars et cinq
secondes pour prendre tout ce que tu  Je veux que tu
répondes à cette question, d'accord,
allez, ce qui fait huit fois huit
soixante-quatre plus dix
soixante-quatorze, d'accord, ouais, prends
ce que tu veux.
attrape ce que tu
veux
attrape ce que tu veux cinq
quatre
attrape juste ce que tu
veux bien la raison pour laquelle j'ai choisi ce gars
parce que je l'ai vu dans la rue j'étais
comme s'il en avait probablement plus besoin que
quiconque
il le fait ici en ce moment dans ce
communauté,
la chose la plus importante est en fait d'
aider les gens
qui sont vraiment importants si vous êtes dans une
bonne position où vous pouvez aider les gens
et que vous avez une bodega quelque chose d'aussi
simple que ça pourrait vraiment changer
la vie d'une personne, vous savez
mak  e les excités les font se sentir vraiment
bien dans leur peau et
vous font vous sentir vraiment bien parce que vous
faites quelque chose de très bien
mais vous donnez beaucoup d'argent
et beaucoup de choses
comment allez-vous comment travaillez-vous cela euh
peu importe  je fais une semaine
je l'utilise si je n'en ai plus je
sors juste des trucs du registre sur
ma poche de mon père combien
tu gagnes par semaine
comme environ comme si je ne travaillais pas autant d'
heures donc 200
250 vous savez
et c'est comme deux trois vidéos
quatre vidéos parfois en fonction de
combien j'ai dépensé pour la vidéo
mais oui donc vous donnez la majeure partie de
votre salaire
oui je le crois ou non et mon père
m'aide
mon père est un vraiment  un gars sympa tu sais
parce que mon père aime donner
donc ça ne le dérange pas et nous allons être
récompensés tu sais
par dieu
[Musique]
je sais que
je suis venu en 1986. ce pays est un grand
pays
les états unis  un grand pays
honneur j'étudie un peu
et puis j'ai travaillé car j'ai un grand
bac de famille  k à la maison
je fais 12 heures parfois je fais 14 heures
parfois ils font plus
tu ne gagnes pas vraiment beaucoup d'argent
mais c'est ce que tu vois comme tu pourrais
savoir t'aider avec ton
entonnoir comme tu sais ouais
c'est une guerre là-bas  et c'est aussi
corona
ils ne font pas bien vraiment ce n'est pas
comme ici ils sont dans une mauvaise situation
alors nous essayons de les aider d'ici
quoi que nous n'ayons pas d'émeute affamée
que pensez-vous de ces euh ces
tic-tac
et les défis moi euh vraiment c'est
super
mais juste eux ils vous savez qu'ils
perdent beaucoup de temps dessus et
ils devraient vous concentrer sur
autre chose
vous savez non non non vous ne pouvez pas mettre ça
là-dedans
vous ne pouvez pas mettre ça et nous ne pouvons pas nous concentrer sur
je sais que c'est ce que nous faisons en ce
moment
ouais l'université c'est bien ouais l'université c'est
bien mais j'ai l'impression que
tu sais tic tac et le
monde des médias sociaux pourrait vraiment faire une différence dans
notre vie si nous mettons vraiment
notre esprit nous pourrions influencer un  beaucoup de
gens à faire super nous pourrions faire
euh nous pourrions commencer  nous pourrions commencer je ne connais pas d'
organisme de bienfaisance
et avoir un gofundme fou nous pourrions changer
la vie de beaucoup de gens avec ça
mon père est trop gentil il ne se rend même pas compte
qu'il soutient en fait tu sais
pour lui ce n'est vraiment
rien mais c'est quelque chose et  c'est
ce qui me motive vraiment,
ça me fait faire mieux tu sais qu'il
ne considère même pas que
je donne autant parce
que c'est comme ça qu'il est gentil
et j'ai dit aux enfants qui en ont besoin
presque tu sais que
ça ne va pas nous tuer et j'espère
tout le monde pourrait faire la même chose nous aimons
ça c'est utile pour tout le monde ouais
merci  tu
ouais nous sommes tu sais depuis quelques années
maintenant presque toute notre enfance tu
sais maintenant nous sommes des hommes adultes nous avons des barbes
tu sais que le
temps passe vite
c'est un peu ghetto ici mais c'est
très amusant c'est beaucoup euh
c'est un  beaucoup d'obstacles mais si vous trouvez
la plate-forme  ht groupe d'amis
oh ouais c'est vrai et le bon groupe
de personnes tu seras bon
ah il va bien sympa de te voir mon pote d'
accord je viendrai au magasin ouais
tu peux me frapper sur tic tac d'
accord j'ai  vous en tant qu'ami si le
truc des médias sociaux ne fonctionne pas que
ferez-vous
je continue à faire tout ce que
j'essaie d'aider avec l'argent que je gagne et de
soutenir ma famille vous savez
et j'essaie d'aller au paradis  je ne vais pas
mentir